ليس سرًا أن الحركة مفيدة للجسم
ووجدت دراسة جديدة المزيد من الأدلة على أنه من
الجيد أيضًا للعقل أنهم
أخذوا 4500 فردًا في المملكة المتحدة قاموا
بربط جهاز مراقبة النشاط على
فخذهم ونظروا إلى ما
فعلوه خلال النهار  كم من الوقت كانوا
ينامون عندما كانوا نشيطين عندما كانوا
غير نشيطين بعد أن
أعطى باحثو النشاط أولئك الذين خضعوا للدراسة
اختبارًا إدراكيًا وجدوا أن
الأشخاص الذين مارسوا أقل من 10 دقائق من
التمارين المعتدلة إلى القوية كل يوم
شهدوا تحسنًا في الذاكرة قصيرة المدى
والوظيفة التنفيذية  مما يساعد في
أشياء مثل التخطيط والتنظيم ،
كان العكس صحيحًا أيضًا إذا
انتقلت إلى أسفل من النشاط المعتدل أو
القوي نحو المزيد من النوم الخامل.
كان التحسن متواضعًا وجد الباحثون أن
الفوائد نمت مع قضاء المزيد من الوقت في
القيام بمزيد من التدريبات المفعمة بالحيوية ،
وعادة ما يتم تعريف النشاط البدني المعتدل
على أنه المشي السريع عن طريق ركوب الدراجات أو الركض
صعودًا ونزولًا على الدرج ، والحركة القوية
مثل الجري والسباحة وركوب الدراجات أعلى
التل سيعزز معدل ضربات القلب
والتنفس.  يتكهنون أنه يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
زيادة التروية الدماغي أو
تدفق الدم إلى عقلك ، هناك
حاجة إلى دراسة إضافية ، لكن الباحثين يقولون إنه حتى
التغييرات الصغيرة يمكن أن تحدث فرقًا كبيرًا
في صحة الدماغ من أجل الصحة دقيقة أنا
آندي جاثر